so I think the economic motive for
Microsoft for doing all this is is very
clear they want to sell Windows and they
want to sell sequel server and they want
to sell that entire stack of stuff and
that entire stack of stuff doesn't have
a very good track record of working well
with the other side of things the open
source side of things so if that's not
true then you pretty much have to do
everything yourself I find that most
micro shop shops are exactly that
they're Microsoft shops they use
Microsoft from from top to bottom
everything is Microsoft it's Microsoft
version control is Microsoft database
server it's Microsoft web servers is
Microsoft developing languages is
Microsoft everything and they get some
benefits of sort of the virtual
integration from that but it also makes
the community very insular in my mind
I've met a fair number of Microsoft
people who just know a lot of my
Microsoft stuff and I mean that's fair
it's just not the same kind of people
that we really associate with otherwise
versus on the open source sort of things
like I talked to plenty of people
working in Python or other languages or
frameworks there's much more I think and
sharing of ideas between the different
camps on that other line like it's sort
of pretty much open source or not open
source if you're in the open source
world you talk to other open source
developers and look at other open source
solutions if you're on this sort of
proprietary closed whatever you want to
call it Microsoft side of the things you
you just stay in your own camp so it
makes perfect business sense to me for
them to to devote all this time to it I
don't know if it makes business sense
for a lot of shops to choose that most
of the time it doesn't seem to pan out
like I would never want to start my
business using stuff that would add up
to heavy heavy license fees once you get
into the open source mint
callate and mindset there's just
something almost offensive about that
just think I don't want to be locked in
to somebody else's platform that I can't
actually change it comes down to sort of
a fundamental sense of freedom do I have
the freedom to change and switch out and
substitute the tools that I'm using with
or am I bound to some master and I've
picked what I find to be to be freedom
in that sort of dichotomy even if it's a
little contrived
I think that Microsoft is still a huge
and profitable company and will be for a
very long time I think that they're
dying by a thousand cuts
but those styles and cuts might take a
thousand years to inflict a mortal wound
what I enjoy most o is unlike the 90s
where you have to care and almost fear
Microsoft that they were the big bully
and they could control everything today
for me they're irrelevant
I don't care they have no bearing on
what I do I don't have to use any
Microsoft technology I don't have to use
Windows for this or any of their tools
for that and in fact I don't and haven't
for a very long time I sort of still
have to care about internet explorer and
making the web apps I create work on
their stuff but even that is becoming
less of a concern gone are the days of
internet explorer having 95 percent
market share long long gone now it's
just sort of a nuisance oh crap we have
to deal with ie6 alright but there's a
big difference between fearing the
800-pound gorilla and then just waving
it flies ah
these are annoying flies get out of my
face so to me I don't know I have talked
to the past about it's that kind of feel
sad like there was something interesting
about having that evil empire there
there is something a rallying cry
actually for the open-source movement
around or we're against the evil
Microsoft people now they're not there
anymore the evil genius has left the
building and now you just have a sales
organization that pushes stuff out to
grey boxes and corporations that I
really don't have to deal with that much
so it's more just for me sad that
they've been relegated to irrelevance
from my perspective I'm sure they're
still relevant for a lot of people and
they have to use it or even heck enjoy
using it we are def not sound from for
my
spective but again big world lots of
room
no longer do you have to fear the
gorilla so so that's good we can just go
on with our business and not worry about
them coming in and stomping on stuff
I think the wonderful thing about the
web is just that it's a level playing
field there is no one company that
controls it in no important way like it
used to be in the past with the Windows
monopoly or it is today in some senses
with sort of the iPhone iPad or Android
platforms on the web you work for nobody
else on the web you work for yourself
and you can pick the tools that you
please for it
that's why Ruby and rails happened for
me if I had had to build OS 10
applications or Windows applications I
would have had to use the tooling that
those masters provided me with because
that's usually how it goes yeah you can
develop with something else but if you
want that native good experience you
damn well better use their tool and go
in and be a sharecropper in their fields
on the web there's no such thing it's an
open standard as long as you can
generate HTML which is something that
everybody has sort of agreed upon how
should how should be read you can use
whatever you damn please so that's
really special and I think that we
sometimes take that for granted it's
easy to forget that it didn't used to be
like this it didn't used to be I'm so
open and so free where you can just use
anything you wanted and the user
wouldn't care in the end you can make
the best web application in the world
with any programming language in the
world which is just incredible freedom
and incredible freedom for innovation
new upstarts new frameworks new
languages they can all play on the same
field and there's not
[Music]